[Music]
in what happened News will have
submitted by sleeping dogs [ __ ] those
dogs man dogs is that game the game game
well that's the cutest gang name ever
dude sleeping dog muscle smell da WGS Oh
dogs sounds cute sleeping thought I'll
ever see that dog that got digestive
problems so the oh he sits down on that
baby single owner so the dog knows what
to do so it sits on this like dog-shaped
chair thing where it has a tray that
comes down and the dog lifts its hands
up push the tray down himself that [ __ ]
dad it's so cute yeah we thought when
they feed themselves no nothing
doesn't eat himself no it looks like a
baby chair yeah actually knit though the
dog sits upright on it by himself and he
brings the [ __ ] tray down because
there's a tray where you could put the
dog bowl and it was suggestive problems
that's how he yeah so he needs wait does
it sit on two legs on his butt but it
sits up and it goes and it brings it
down again sweetie you ever seen a dog
walking on two legs before it is the
scariest [ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
you ever seen a pug do a handstand and
piss all over the place yeah a guy on
ambien accidentally proposed to his
girlfriend accidentally you didn't want
to do it this Abiah [ __ ] is making the
people do a lot of wild [ __ ] is it the
trap of both the rose and I'm like it
tisha inhibition soy so you say it's
already inside let me to Ike I want to
try it like this dude he took like four
times ago citrus why cause he couldn't
sleep has insomnia and like one dosage
doesn't do it for him so he did it like
way more than you should have
that'd be nice if it was truth assume
yeah what was an bar lost her show over
four of those and he or over one of them
he gonna take four so she says well
maybe so what happens is it's the
combination of ambien and alcohol that
that is a crazy thing it's not it's not
like hearsay either you're not supposed
to a cadmium with alcohol and it does
some kind of weird like psychosis
affects you so that's the whole Roseanne
Barr thing yeah but
your target if your target audience is
women who can't sleep I'll wash it down
with a glass of wine you know
let's think about that yeah because it's
not yep this dude he even hosted on
subreddit today I [ __ ] it Oh today I
[ __ ] up so this is what he said you
think you [ __ ] up by proposing you
thought the dumper just maybe it's how
you did it I want to start off by saying
that ambien is a strongest drug slash
slash Hallucigenia and you should not
[ __ ] with it ok now I want to take it I
know man I'm sold
and IANS a hell what if it makes me the
most normal person like it does the
opposite effect we don't know we don't
want that for you dude
stay weird I don't want it to [ __ ] up my
sleep powers though my sleep powers are
really good I don't want to [ __ ] with
this Oh see you're thinking it's like
the what's the penis pills like viagra
like that yeah so I'm scared of you
might never wake up that [ __ ] [ __ ]
though I want to take it and go I don't
think that's what happens she's sleepy
you're gonna have alcohol plus a
sleeping pill you're just gonna go to
sleep okay because I think it affects
people with insomnia differently so then
he continues he says anyways one night I
just couldn't sleep so I decided to take
for 10 milligram ambience parentheses
I'm an idiot sounds like a lot had an
engagement ring in my drawer that I
traded for some other jewelry because I
buy and sell stuff on Craigslist woke up
and she was wearing the ring on her
finger and had explained what had
happened what had happened well it's
just said yes and then he continues and
I was just shook because I couldn't
remember [ __ ] I go on my facebook and
apparently my ambien drugged brain
changed my relationship says so he was
happy engaged yeah and it took and it
got 150 plus likes before I [ __ ] saw
it and then it went viral for him so now
he can't back up because now he's cool
I had not
and I'm being engaged with my girlfriend
for another year and a half and probably
would have gotten her a better ring but
ambien sped up the process tenfold
morning it's 3:00 a.m. and you can't
sleep do not take and he doesn't even
remember what he did so that's probably
what he's more like oh so he woke her up
at 3:00 a.m. I got it dude sleeping
problems [ __ ] suck dude like I've
dealt with that ship for the longest
that sucks but a lot of the stuff too
like that I think that helped me a lot
was the holistic approach of stuff so
people think that medication is always
the solution but they haven't even tried
the natural [ __ ] going outside
exercising drinking water drinking what
like exercising is the biggest thing
that people just don't try no like have
you ever worked out to [ __ ] exhausted
you will not get well not kind of
marijuana so I would do that right but
then I would knock out too early so I
will knock out during the day and then
I'd be up and then I'd be [ __ ] you just
need like moderate exercise but
frequency and throughout the day
something instead of like an intense
one-hour session man you're just so
exhausted you go to sleep also two
people have too much wine the your cell
phone yeah if you don't put it on that
mine's automatic at 10 p.m. now mine is
like that night shift mode yeah could
you go to sleep and then he's like well
you know that your cell phone does that
I'm like people don't know that if you
just drink enough water and you exercise
and you try to go to sleep at a regular
time and if you can't sleep this seven
eight hours that's 90% of all medical
complications and you probably don't
need pills for anything yeah
but the hard part is people don't want
to change their life to do that stuff
they'd rather take like the headache
medicine this medicine that medicine
because for being the whole like it's
taught me a thing like it's definitely
harder for me to sleep but like for
example like when I'm in Hawaii or
something and I'm traveling I'm rarely
ever on this thing yeah and I'm away
from all these electronics at nighttime
you snore loud as [ __ ]
I knocked up I share a room with him I
know hey I don't know as much now over
what I know you're out so when I hear
you snow it makes me feel good
man I know David can't sleep but he's
sleeping like a [ __ ] dude Hawaii
it's like it's bad I'm like you it
normal normal time because even Nancy
knows like she goes when he's in a car
with me he's gonna be gone so she'll
talk to me for five minutes then I'm
like look let me tell y'all what y'all
need or what you know if you can't sleep
y'all ever try to adult bedtime stories
before what is that that's right yeah so
much it sounds like it's gonna wake me
up making me all horny oh it's not like
I mean adult I mean I am an adult and it
is a bedtime story
is it like Samuel Jackson they get all
sexy as [ __ ] that I'm an adult innocent
look so I found they're gonna have
coloring books yes exactly it's not
coloring in dick it's just cuz I'm a
grown-ass woman and I need to color but
so I found this meditation color exactly
I need to color to you look there's a
little there's a little tab and it said
sleep and I was like well let me just
click on this and it was this this read
this little sleepy image and it said the
cat Marina I clicked on that [ __ ] this
dude comes on he says boats and cats a
nice bedtime story for everyone and then
there's like a soft cat meow
I was out so fast and you said me that
[ __ ] yes I can do this me too I'm here I
mean seriously it's not that type of
story deal okay both [ __ ] dude dude I
mean I'm telling you boy I've been
having trouble sleeping for 15 years
since I was a child and this [ __ ] came
on and I woke up the Sun was the birds
were chirping and [ __ ] you hear how
stuff this [ __ ] came in though and
dropped the bomb on us she waited for
all of us to talk about the drugs we
wanted to take and the [ __ ] that you've
been doing and why the stuff she was
just sitting there she's like I'm about
to attack dude look I quit smoking weed
and I started listening to bedtime
stories that's right
I changed my life so if you don't have
bedtime stories can you still sleep No
you go some night sometimes you and your
future Charlie have so much in common
dude I mean I do it every night but then
like also there's this one where he
talks about its snowy forest means like
today we're gonna be traveling in a very
unusual way inside of a bubble there was
snowy forest that is can you just report
your voice cuz I you know I really want
to do I really wanted to do like a
YouTube thing where I did like ASMR but
it was really bad [ __ ] that happens it's
like you're on a quiet beach you see a
hand coming out of the sand
[Laughter]
it starts out call me what it does I'm
gonna do that to Mariel dude I'm gonna
have her listen to some audio [ __ ] have
a fall sleep and then I'm gonna switch
my voice out your boyfriend is never
wrong you're wrong apologize be naked
all the time in the room when you see
your boyfriend you have the urge to take
off where you walk into the house go on
your knees and bow down with your hands
like this is like popsicles it's a warm
summer day you need a popsicle in those
stories they're just 20 minutes 20
minutes you're just out just thinking
about already but you and I don't have
the stories sometimes I just imagine
myself in a bubble you're already
wearing your blanket the sexual version
of it will be even better huh no because
they don't yes like Gio said it'd be all
hot wake up all hot I'm turning 30
because I just was like getting all hot
getting all hot and bothered by this
story oh my god somebody's bad this
flower I'm a whittling meditation app
for it cuz they have a sleep thing too
mm-hmm they're telling you like you know
BRE like hole didn't like breathe in for
four seconds holding it in for six and
breathe out for eight or some [ __ ] and
I'm like but just hearing the the music
and the soothing voice no matter what it
is yes sometimes I don't even follow
what they're saying but just hearing it
the thing where you follow your toes up
into your ankles and kneecaps I mean
there's this app thing where you
visualize a light in each part of your
toe to your body to and you turn off
that light everywhere
go and so you're supposed to visualize
that [ __ ] and then by the time you get
to the top of your head I think it's
like Oh some Buddhist monk [ __ ] though
originally but they were doing that and
it didn't work for me like I just kept
picturing this cool little light and
then for some reason eternity like a
highway there was a car accident and
also the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] I don't know
headlights no because that that's too
much mind work for me like I'm on count
I'm gonna breathe like I'm gonna do that
and like in the the one that I listen to
he does do some of those reading
exercises but you hear the water in the
background and I didn't hand me out and
he's all soft the [ __ ] I'm like you
gonna hug me like that's you know that's
what I want when I lay down and by the
time I stick my hand behind my pillow to
that cool spot I'm not [ __ ] talking
to him and he's already twitching I'm
like what he's like good night and then
I'm like okay he's like twitching like
sleeps Sleeping Beauty and Cinderella
put together cuz around 12 he just goes
Matt 12:10
you're right ten earlier than 12 you
gave him too much credit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]